my name is ryan brush
and today i want to talk about how we
can make our code simpler by
using some ideas that we see in expert
systems and then we're going to take a
look at
an open source implementation of these
patterns in closure
but i think a lot of this but what about
what we're going to talk today really
applies to a lot of different
programming problems in a lot of
different languages
so we're going to start with a story and
the story
starts in an era in which real computers
were still moved around with forklifts
and uh it was in 1977 and uh
we start in 1977 because that was the
year that this man edward fragenbaum
quipped that intelligent systems derived
their power
from the knowledge they possess rather
than those formalisms used
uh and this you know maybe it seems
obvious at the surface maybe it seems
obvious today
but i think this opens up a number of
deeper questions about how we
should build our systems and these are
questions that i feel like we don't have
a great answer to yet
so for instance if the knowledge is the
most important piece how do we manage
that knowledge so we can
i'll make sure that we're all thinking
about the same thing that we have a
shared understanding of this knowledge
so that we can build upon and maintain
it
also how do we manage the semantic gap
the distance
between what the domain knowledge is and
what our code looks like
and if that gap grows if our code stops
looking like what that expertise is how
do we keep that in sync how do we
enhance the code in order to stay close
to what this expertise is
and really if experts in a domain if
they think in these kind of composable
units of knowledge if they
think in terms of information that we
can build on top of each other
can we model how experts think about
problems in our systems itself
thereby making it a lot easier to manage
what the system does
and how domain experts think about it
and this started to take off this was a
big problem
in the late 70s well skipped 1979
and that was an important year because
this was the year
that charles forgee published his phd
thesis that's on the
efficient implementation of production
systems
and the key to that thesis is that
charles 4g had an insight in that
if we take rules that look like this
and then if you have half many thousands
of them working with many thousands or
tens of thousands or
more data elements it simply isn't
practical to run
all of your data against all of your
rules so even if we wanted to codify
knowledge in terms of rules in terms of
how an expert might think about the
problem we
didn't have an efficient way to do it so
4g's insight was
well in most domains there's commonality
between these rules even if it's
single expressions there's things that
we're evaluating over and over again
so rather than trying to run all the
rules against all the data let's take
this let's slice them up
and then build a network of commonality
between these rules
so rather than dumping everything
against every rule only things that can
match and data just flows through this
network
and suddenly we could take very complex
knowledge bases we could codify
that domain expertise and we could run
it really reasonably efficiently
against these rule sets and this is a
big deal and this this kind of launched
an industry and this industry really
took off it gained a lot of momentum
and perhaps rising to its peak in the
mid 1980s
uh in systems that context that looked
like this this is
nasa's mission control and in 1985
starting in 1985 nasa was running the
mission control for multiple spacecraft
including the space shuttle
using these expert systems using this
all this codified knowledge of
all the inputs that we need to look at
how do we handle all these
all these pieces of information in order
to operate these
incredibly complex pieces of machinery
so
there was success on these rules engines
complement them they solved some
really hard real world problems and of
course that success
started to grow and led to some more
excitement uh getting to the 1980s uh
we rule engines new businesses new
companies started to build them
the problem is is that these expert
systems they usually didn't run on
computers that look like this
they usually ran on computers that look
like this
and this is a symbolic lisp
machine the idea being that hey if we
build hardware that we can
run directly on we can beat the
performance of
a more general computing turns out that
wasn't really true
this was being undercut by much simpler
computers by much simpler
instructions instruction sets and so
this investment in these expert systems
was being undercut
but that really wasn't enough to to
to deal a really hard blow to these
companies what really was
is that they were over hyped we could
find material from the era here's
1990 from from infoworld that frankly a
lot of intellectually dishonest promises
were made
we saw expert systems we solved some
problems with them and then as so often
it's happened time and time again
in ai systems that if there's so much
excitement builds up
and then we can't scale them that led to
the second ai winter in the 1980s
the first one was uh something similar
that in the early 1970s
so our story continues we'll pick up in
the 1990s and
and this kind of arc may look familiar
and
it may look like the hype wave where we
have a new technology
excitement succeeds all reasonable
expectations
and then we crash down realizing hey
it's not going to do all that stuff
and then we'd expect if it does follow
if rural engines did
follow this sort of hype way we'd expect
to be climbing back up it
would expect it to be regaining that
momentum to make a practical use
and this happened it happened sort of
and this is where i think our story took
a wrong turn
during that recovery from the hype cycle
of expert systems
and i think part of the reason it took a
wrong turn is that we have to look at
what else was going on
in that time period what was going on in
the 1990s and here we have a graph of
uh the employment level for people that
call themselves information
technology workers i mean it's kind of a
broad group but it's a proxy for what's
going on
in the trend there was a huge demand for
developers
there wasn't a supply to meet them um
and this
huge demand well it ended up creating
essentially a secondary demand
in that if we could find ways to solve
problems that
may have required code then yeah let's
let's do that so
uh we'll ignore the logical
contradiction in this because well
a lot of people did in that era as well
but it's really easy
to look at i mean if i see this if i see
rule when this than that
like do i need a programmer to write
this no i mean yeah somebody can write
this and
and as an engineer that you know this
even sounds a little bit appealing to me
i mean
as as a developer because trust me i
have no shortage of things to go do
if the the business folks want to you
know handle this piece of it
let them i'm happy happy to do that
uh and martin fowler observed this trend
several years later in that the central
pitch of rules engines has become
uh business people allow allow business
people to specify
independently without involving
programmers
uh he went on to say that this usually
doesn't end well
for reasons that we're going to jump
into
and because this demand our rule enters
our expert systems their tools started
being targeting business users it
started
rather than engineers so we started
seeing these very limited
mini languages emerge in order to
express our logic or even decision
tables
in spreadsheets and sure if you have a
simple problem if you have an example
problem
uh and and even some constrained use
cases it can work right and
you know if we're living in that world
in which a decision table in a
spreadsheet or a really simple language
meets your needs then great yes we're
set
the thing is is that those problems
usually don't say simple
and so we end up with things like this
where we have a tool that targets a
business user and we end up with a
pile of java if a pile java code then
another pile of java code
what did we really buy ourselves here we
said we're writing java with a
drl file now it doesn't really buy us
much and
then similarly with this uh putting in
decision tables
and it looks clean i know you can't read
the the specific text in there but
i mean if you could you would see that
yeah yeah that's that's java code in
excel spreadsheet there's a couple other
examples of it
so i don't think that anyone woke up one
morning and came in and a green pressure
problem says everyone i figured it out
we can solve this
problem by writing java code in excel i
i
i don't think anyone actually ever did
that um
but i think that that what this does is
i mean this is a work around
this is a work around that tells us that
the approach that
was taken to solve this class of
problems isn't optimal
there's this it says that there should
be a better way if you end up
right find yourself in a position where
you're writing java code in an excel
spreadsheet
you're probably going down the wrong
path
and the fact is is that rule authoring
well you know what it's it's development
it is how what's the difference between
a rule and a function i mean even if
it's in a trivial sense even it's a
simple rule
it's development whether we call it that
or not
so what if we turn this on its head what
if we take this approach they
take this industry we demand was a rose
to
write code without developers and we
kind of lost our grasp
on these expert systems as programmers
so let's turn it on its head
let's uh what if we approach expert
systems as code
so a lot of times when we write code we
can think of let's we have some data
let's hear we have a and b
and then we'll do trans some sort of
transformation on this now
in some languages uh these
transformations maybe
update something in place and we put a
new value in a functional language it'll
take
these inputs and produce a new outputs
it it doesn't really matter that much in
this context
so much of what we do is we take inputs
and then we build on them and we emit
something else
and and this applies to a lot of domains
whether it's uh
we're doing expense reports for
traveling we can we can might have to
account for a contract budget and
justifications or
if we're putting together our sales
package we might look at their history
or in the domain that i work in in
healthcare
we have a whole bunch of inputs to
determine hey what sort of plan of care
that do we need to live in do we need to
deliver
so this is applicable in a lot of places
but our challenge is we have to wire
these things together
and this gets a little more involved i
mean at
right here this looks pretty simple but
when we start wiring everything together
taking
all the inputs from one function wiring
them into the inputs of the next
and composing it and then once we even
have all those wired
it gets a little it's even more
complicated because suppose we introduce
some new input suddenly i'm rewiring a
whole bunch of my functions
and if you're if in a domain in which
your nested functions only go a couple
deep
yeah you can go through this you can
refactor your code you can pass the data
that you need to the function that needs
it
but then we get into these worlds in
really complex domains in which
our functions are many layers deep and
suddenly i want to pass something into
something that's deep down in there and
then you know so you're suddenly
refactoring your code and making sure
everything's there
or doing something truly hideous and
you're creating like a global variable
or something like that just because
you can't touch all the code or uh it
we don't have a great solution even i
mean i'm
i'm a big proponent of a functional
approach to programming but i feel like
you know we still can get
our code can still get tangled even with
this functional
approach and if we try and do this with
thousands of requirements for different
sources
it gets really complicated and it just
comes down to the fact that
this explicit wiring this way of tying
everything together that we have to do
by hand
is error-prone and so let's ask
ourselves can we do this
automatically i mean can we wire these
things up automatically
so let's look at this and ask how we
could do it
the first thing that we notice when we
look at this on the left side of the
screen is that how
these functions should be wired is
actually unambiguous
i mean we can see that that everyone
that
uh when we emit something new we can see
where it gets wired and the other one
uh and since it's unambiguous it should
be able to automate it
right and so what if we described the
set of functions as these units of logic
where every input that we take is
specified as a type
and that type can be you know whatever
type system exists
in the host language that you're working
with and a set of constraints to say you
know what subset
of of the data that you're interested in
that function
and we're going to dive into how that's
possible but really
and this this is essentially looks like
a rule like you might see in an expert
system
but applied in the context of you know
line in line with the rest of our code
base
and this is i mean so really we're
viewing rules
as a type of control structure something
that we can integrate it in with the
rest of our code
in order to simplify all this nasty
explicit wiring
that we have to do otherwise and now i
want to look at
how we could actually apply this how we
could implement it
and so i'm going to take a look at what
i'm calling a principal design
for rules as a control structure and by
this i mean
i think that if we can take a couple few
premises a couple
basic assertions we can come up with a
design
for how we could implement rules and
make it a first class participant
in our development process so we'll
start with
really the the proven model this is how
expert systems
generally work we'll have a working
memory which contains
all the knowledge uh uh that our our
system has
uh i mean uh and these each unit of
knowledge is typically
referred to as a fact so uh the fact
that uh
alice has hypertension in the healthcare
domain that would be a fact a unit of
knowledge
uh then we match those facts against a
knowledge base uh so if if alice has
hypertension then we might
prescribe some medication and then we
can infer new information
say the medication that we should
prescribe
and and then we just this goes in a
cycle until you know the system
normalizes and we have
all the derived information in our
working memory
so in code we can map this to code we
have a simple unit of logic
in this case it would basically be a
rule each
every input has a type and we can apply
this to whatever type system
the language exists that we're
implementing this
in so even dynamic languages you know
even if it's if it's a dynamic type
system we can match hey
how should we wire up our inputs and
we'll go into examples
of how we can do this we want to specify
the constraints for what subset of input
maybe i'm not interested in everything
that matches a certain type but only
things that match certain criteria
show examples of that as well
when our function fires uh we want to
unify the perspective
unify the input of it so for instance if
we're looking at
a lab results and say some sort of
medical history of a person
if we have multiple people in our memory
data we want to unify we want to make
sure that
both the lab results and the medical
history are looking at the same person
and you can apply this to any domain
whether i mean
i mean we're talking about health care
but things like if it's a it's a
customer and order history i mean just
almost anything we can can apply this
pattern too
but this gives us a consistent view of
the data that's passed into our function
and then finally we can have arbitrary
actions that fire on the right-hand side
and then the last piece that we see in
these expert systems is truth
maintenance
where if it's true that if we have some
data element that
a asserts that b is true if a becomes
false
if they no longer qualify for some
reason we want to retract
that particular piece of information
from the system
so to keep everything in a consistent
state
and so this really brings rules as a
first class participant
into our development process and there's
actually a few systems out there that
follow a pattern that's similar to this
to varying degrees
so nulls is a nice javascript version it
uses some pre-processing
logic there's a wongi and ruby the one
we're going to focus on
is clara a closure implementation of
this pattern
it's open source it's out on github i'll
put
a link at the end of this talk and i
think that
clojure is actually perhaps uniquely
best positioned to tackle this sort of
problem
part of it is that it emphasizes data
over objects so if we have as we write
rules and expressions
we want to simply easily access our data
versus having to dig through you know
some object model
equality means something and i'll show
an example of why this is important when
we jump into the code a little bit
and that clojure has well-defined
equality semantics for all types and
and really if you're if you're working
with
any form of logic programming and just
something as basic as saying whether two
things are equal and knowing that they
will always be equal and not being able
to mutate them underneath us
really simplifies how we can reason
about our systems a lot and we can
leverage that extensively by doing this
enclosure
clojure has great reach in terms of the
jvm and the system that i'll show here
also
compiles to javascript and we can use uh
i'm sorry yeah via clojurescript it
compiles to javascript
and then we can also plug into java
beans in this system
assuming you know they behave well and
that you don't mutate them underneath
the rule engine
and uh really and the biggest thing is
the ability to con
to grow the language of closure and this
is in the sense of
guy steel's famous growing language talk
uh in this case
using macros so if we look back
uh we can look back at those rules we
have and this is actually valid syntax
enclosure so modeling those those very
simple hypertension rules
and the way that this system works the
way clara works is that essentially
by using macros that we can take these
declarative structures
and transform them at compile time or
just before
runtime into the same reading network
that charles forgive posted now really
has
evolved quite a bit over the years it's
not exactly an implementation of his
paper it
works in collections of data elements
rather than individuals it'll build
indexes in the nodes but
it's still that same basis of building a
rules engine
on top of these these simple
infrastructures so with that
we're going to take a quick look at some
of the code here
for what clara does so let's keep out of
that
all right uh so so this is just a valid
clojure file there's nothing uh
unique about this at all uh nothing
special about this
um requiring just some things that we'll
use in the demo uh
let's early on these are just some
records and some functions that i'll use
below uh these are all defined using the
prismatic schema library just because
it's nice to have
you know clear what a clear definition
of what your structure looks like
but we don't need them to be uh schema
prismatic schema records they can be
an arbitrary closure data structure that
we can destructure in arbitrary ways
and as i mentioned a little bit ago they
can also be java beans
so let's take a look at our the first
rule and in this case we're simply
saying
hey if a blood pressure between these
ranges
then we infer that this person is
hypertensive
and what we see here this is actually uh
is an indication that
that binds the person id to this
variable
and so thereby making it visible on the
right hand side
of our rule and it's also used for
unification as we'll show below
so this another rule basically does
something pretty similar looks at a
different range
now this is where we start getting a
little more interesting
one of our big challenges like in code
in general is how
do we make things composable we're we're
good at thinking about things in
individual pieces if i don't have to
juggle so many balls
i can only juggle so many balls at a
time but in this case
what we can do is we can compose rules
on top of other ones
so if i assert that somebody is
hypertensive in this case i can catch
hey this person is hypertensive under
certain criteria
and use that in some rule that builds on
top of it and this assertion for
i'm recommending some medications this
may be picked up by some other
rule the other interesting thing about
this one is we see
an instance of a very simple instance of
unification
in that here we have a variable by
convention we use
a pre prefixed question mark on on the
symbol name to indicate it
but uh here we bind you know person id
to this and here we you know bind it to
the same thing
the rule ends and will ensure that these
are unified and so if i have
rules from multiple people inside the
system you know we'll be ensure that
each individual invocation
only gets you know one only gets that
one person id
and in this case we unify on uh
on just an identifier but we can really
unify on any arbitrary structural type
and that's
that's one of the advantages of the fact
that equality means something it's like
you can unify two things because they
are equal
and it has well-defined semantics in
closure
and the other thing that's interesting
to point out is that uh i mean these
unifications are actually
i mean these are done by you know
parsing the code and detecting the need
for unification
but everything in here is a just a valid
closure expression so this is just a
closure
or expression um here we're looking for
people person people over 60. so this is
a closure function that i defined
up above the particular data elements
that are visible here
so by default what we'll do is we'll
look at the fields of the record
and then make those visible to your ex
to the context of your expressions
if you have a more specialized need if
you know your way around closure pretty
well
we can do arbitrary destructuring
destructuring of the facts
and to make it visible make it visible
to the functions as well
and then the right hand side again it's
just it's a closure expression
and in this case it inserts uh some sort
of uh
some derived information which is a
pretty common pattern to just simply do
an
insertion or of this new information
uh we can also do side effects as well
uh
uh in use cases where it makes sense so
maybe
you might have a function here that says
fire alarm or something like that and
then
uh and then we can deactivate that alarm
when useful so
i'll just browse through the next few
rules but i mean you can kind of see
that
these are all composing on top of we
take some of our previous information
and we build on top of that where
we were determining whether uh if we can
determine if this is a high-risk patient
uh based on whether they have a referral
and then chronic kidney disease and
by the way this is completely fabricated
rules do not take medical advice from
this code
shows the examples but uh so let's look
let's look at this
in action um and so really what i can do
is is
that for make session it just creates a
new rule session
if you're not familiar with closure this
is the threading macro it'll just
thread the output of one function into
the next one so we can make a session
by default i mean this is a macro it'll
actually load all the rules in the
current namespace by default
you can pass in a sequence of namespaces
as an optional argument to this if you
have we want to load rules from a bunch
of namespaces
so here we create a session we insert
some facts
we fire the rules and then we run a
query to in this case
above we had a query that recommends
medications and we spit that out
so we'll go ahead and here i'll make a
little more room at the bottom here
so if we go ahead and run that you can
see that our query returned
for person id one you know i just use
one for all the person ids here
and then it returns hey we infer this
person
needs a medication of listener pro
so that's the simplest example the other
thing that we can do following this
pattern since we are
writing basically making rules as a
control structure in a host language
we really want to participate as a first
class entity in that we want to follow
the idioms the best practices
of the host language enclosure involves
values immutability really strongly
which i think is important i think that
this is
everything's tending trending towards
immutability and so we follow that here
in that what i can do is i can define a
session and insert
just a little bit of data now if i run a
query against that
it returns an empty sequence because
there's nothing that matched there's no
recommended medications
but here's where it gets interesting i
can take my initial session which
i've just defined up above insert some
new information
then fire that now if i query the second
session that we get
we have that recommendation but the
first one is unchanged
and so everything that we do every
modification every assertion every mod
everything we do to the working memory
isn't really modifying that working
memory it's a pure function it's
producing a new working memory
with that shared information now it
shares a huge amount of state internally
so this is actually
efficient uh clojure has great
structures great persistent data
structures and great ways
in order to make transient changes to
them as well
uh so it turns out that even though
we're logically creating a new working
memory
i've profiled this for a number of use
cases it's actually performance is
pretty equivalent to drools even with
the mutable working memory state and so
i think that's frankly as much a
testament to uh to
the closure data structures that that
this is even possible
and then and this and then similarly
since equality means something if i want
to retract a fact
retract unit of information i can just
create a new one and retract that and
since this blood pressure equals
that previous one we had in the
information in the working memory
it will just retract that based on
equality i don't have to deal with
object handles or things like that or
reference
external references to the units of
information i have if two
records are equal we view them as equals
and it just seems
like a really simplified way to thinking
about the problem
and then and since things are immutable
a common pattern is that we can actually
just create a session with our
with just our knowledge that's empty and
then just reuse that
and we can reuse them as normal
functions so here's a normal closure
function
uh it accepts a sequence of of uh of
person data which is just
can be their medical history and it
returns their recommended medications
so the a consumer of this function
doesn't even need to know that it's
using a rural engine at all
and so this is how we can participate in
a larger ecosystem we can still build
functions that
use rule engines internally it's all
closure code underneath there's no
additional
artifact to deploy or manage um but then
we
but but then we can take that advantage
to simplify our code so if we run
this example function we see here that
that list and
we do a little manipulation in that
function and uh
functions could this one just does a
pretty simple
uh query and returned some structure but
functions could do multiple queries or
to do additional processing i mean
really whatever you need
to meet your the needs of your domain
well and i'm going to touch on one more
thing before we go to the slides and
that the rule structures are actually
also
data in that if i here
if i print out the context of a rule
structure uh this is just a clojure
structure as the documentation the rule
name
the left-hand side uh everything in it
and so the implications of this is that
one is that we can create
tooling to expand to explore our rules
but also
if we have a complex if i want to
implement my logic using
some higher level expression we can
actually generate these rules
and this is actually a pattern that
you've seen a lot i've seen a lot of
people
writing code that just generates drools
rules um
versus some uh being produced from sort
of high level domain specific language
but we can do the same thing here except
instead of just kicking out strings
we're
emitting a data structure that defines
those rules
which then get picked up by a rule
engine
and because it's a data structure we can
do some inspection of it
so i'll make this go away so in this
case
i created a session that inserted some
information
but how often uh when working with a
really complex domain
do we have users asking well why did
this input occur why did why did this
happen
so what we have here is that since the
rule engine
maintains why every fact was asserted
why everything was inferred it has to do
that
in order to maintain its consistency we
can actually print out explanations
and a little challenging and this will
make a little bit smaller there but uh
but you can see that here we have uh
blood pressure with chronic kidney
disease matched because this
hypertension
matched that type under this expression
um
and then if you wanted to track down you
know why uh how we inferred this unit of
information we could go trace that back
as well so we can we so i think this
could be valuable in that
one of our challenges is explainability
when working with really complex systems
how do we explain to the end of the user
and so i'm going to show this which is a
bit more experimental so don't read
too much into it but this is a really a
web visualization of that explanation so
i look click on the hypertense effect i
can see that we inferred that because
there was a blood pressure that matched
this criteria
that then inferred this piece of
information we can look at something a
little more
involved so recommended medications uh
you know this can be hard to read where
we can see hypertensive
and inferred this and we joined it with
this demographic information
and thereby asserted that and yeah these
are all i mean
this is this is more of an experiment uh
at this point and we're using
we're exposing the closure s expressions
but you can imagine tooling if
your users don't like reading a prefix
notation enclosure you could you know
easily convert these to an infix
notation you could provide the user a
visual explanation
of why the system emitted the the data
that it did emit
and frankly this is a lot better than
having engineers
logging in talking around trying to
solve trying to explain to the user if
we can provide
a sort of self-service explanation by
codifying the business needs in these
rules engines
i think that there's some potential that
we can explore there
so i'm going to go back to the slides a
little bit
all right and then a bunch of other
things that i didn't show for the sake
of time
uh in terms of arbitrary expressions
accumulators
i wanted to touch on one other things
that as well and that
uh almost said i'd circle back to the to
edward pegavon's
quote and that did they derive the power
from the knowledge they possess
now a lot of times uh we might think of
it uh
the knowledge they possess and we hope
that we all have the same mental model
in mind
we all see the system the same way but
in practice
language is ambiguous right we have a
different everyone has a different
thought of the system a different view
of it
and i think this is really one of the
great advantages of an agile development
methodology i think this is why these
things gain
one of the things this approach has
gained attraction in that if people have
different
perspectives of the system by iterating
on it we can slowly converge these
perspective we take some sort of minimal
product we build that they say yeah that
looks good this doesn't look good and we
build towards that
shared understanding and that's a good
thing but
for agile but sometimes you have to step
back and think imagine if other
industries
use this same approach i mean i might
get an ambiguous description of a
building it's like oh no that's not
right we really want it to be shorter
or like that or and then they put this
and it's like no we really wanted it to
be green
so we'll just go and drop that i mean
this is actually how
we build software right and it works
it's actually a good way to build
software in a lot of cases
it's a good way to build software when
agile development is cheap
when when iteration is cheap and that i
can quickly iterate and prove these
systems
but our challenge is that iteration
isn't always cheap
uh and i take a look at this so this is
an actual this i didn't make this up and
there's no way you can read it but it's
actually the
i have to read it myself the integrated
defense acquisition technology and
logistics life cycle management
framework
yeah yeah this is real uh can you
imagine being given this
and and asked to implement it and we
could take an agile approach
i mean we could carve off some minimal
viable system uh we could do that we
could write unit tests for that system
but
does that really help us i mean because
we're writing unit tests for the
developers understanding of the system
we're not writing tests for the end
users what they desire
and yeah we can take the minimal system
and give it to the users and have them
click through it
but as we are they going to go through
every permutation of logic flow
in this system every time we iterate uh
i think this is a challenge
and and uh and agile is a challenge when
we have this really deep complexity
that's not on the surface that's not
easily visible to the users where the
unit test we don't really know
it only validates the developers
understanding
so we have to ask ourselves a question
in that what can we learn
from industries where agile doesn't work
and there's a metaphor there
there's a metaphor of where we have
blueprints uh
in these other industries where that's
our and this maps to our code that maps
to
uh and it's an unambiguous specification
that describes our system
but as a lay person i can't really look
at a blueprint and make
sense of it it doesn't help me
understand whether this
the building is or isn't what it does
what i want
but the construction industry does have
a model that helps me understand and
it's a floor plan
and a floor plan what is it it's really
just a simplified projection
of a blueprint it's something that i can
look at and say hey
yeah i like that room i we need to make
this one bigger
it's something that it's something that
we can use to build that shared
understanding to make sure
that the building blueprints the
building design looks like what i want
it to look like before we
begin the construction and that asks
ourselves a question can we learn that
from this
can in instances in which agile
development may struggle
can we create some sort of floor plan
metaphor
in software and so this is we're going
to
take a look at something that along
these lines
so let's go back to our rules and uh so
taking all the logic above what if we
created a visualization
of our logic that users could interact
with
so actually this is this by itself so
i'll zoom out to show the kind of
complexity so
this is the complexity of the rules and
their relationships i mean
so this alone this we're not going to
make so much sense of this but the nice
thing is is that since all of our logic
since our rules
are data we can manipulate that so let's
say i wanted to zoom in on that
particularly how medication
recommendation occurred
so suddenly i have something that's more
manageable i can see
from blood pressure would infer how
they're hypertensive
if all of the above criteria are met i
fire this rule
which recommends medications and then
we can just for fun i made some simple
interaction with it so i could
drill down and look at the source code
if i really wanted to to see what the
relationships of these rules are
and i can zoom out and here we'll look
at another
example here if i want to look at
something a little more involved where
i want to look at whether this person is
a high risk patient oops
and then we can see their relationships
between that those
so and this is something that we can
play with but the nice thing is is that
by expressing our logic as rules in a
language
using a model that our users can
understand we can get a lot closer to
creating these type of
these type of things where it's a it's
it's a floor plan it's a simplified
description
maybe it's a static document you we
generate maybe it's some sort of
interactive
exploration of data um but the nice
thing is is that
by codifying them in a model as in the
terminology and the rules that
domain experts understand we have the
opportunity to start
create projecting creating these
artifacts
and this i think really what it boils
down to is a sort of a new role
for rules in our development process in
that rather than thinking of those rules
as
something that's targeted business users
exclusively
let's look at them as a tool for
developers a way that we can
simplify our code let's look at them as
a way to minimize that semantic gap i
mean the closer our code looks to the
actual desire of the business i think
that
makes things a lot easier to work with a
lot easier to manage a lot easier to
reason about
and i think that they're also a leverage
they're leveraged for
shared understanding they're a mechanism
a leverage something that we can
leverage to create these floor plans
uh to share with our users so we can
make sure that we have this common
understanding of the system
and i think that uh probably most
importantly if you take away anything
uh from this talk i'd have to say uh
just don't write java code in excel
and uh with that uh almost out of time
for questions uh
yeah so i think that i'll be i'll just
be up here if anyone wants to have a
discussion
i would like to thank this started as a
psy project i would like to thank cerner
because
we're starting to work on this and use
this for the assistance we build at
cerner too
it's great fun and we are hiring so um
if you have any questions i'll be up
here
otherwise thank you